all the chaos not all the chaos but a
significant portion of the chaos that
we're seeing in the Middle East right
now is the responsibility of the Iranian
regime right it's okay it's fine it's
the houis it's K Hezbollah it's it's
Hamas it's whatever but they exist
because Iran has built them and has
supported them and has trained them and
has resourced them if the Iranian regime
doesn't have to pay a direct consequence
for this whether that is increased
sanctions that mean something because it
it starts to dry up their oil revenues
or whether it's um you know targeting a
Refinery or something if they don't face
a direct consequence that's exactly what
they want they've built a system where
they can engage in all this instability
and aggressiveness and have their
proxies suffer the consequences right
and so that they can have this very thin
cover of plausible deniability